the tungle me integration with lotus
live allows you to easily initiate
meetings from within the Lotus live
environment when signed into Lotus live
select tungl me from the app's drop down
menu you'll now be directed to your
tungl me account if you don't have a
tungl me account you'll be asked to
create one it's free and takes only a
few minutes to
register from your tongle me account
you'll be able to sync your Lotus Live
contacts and create new meeting
invitations to propose multiple times to
one or many
people you'll also be able to see
schedules of your Lotus Live contacts on
tungl
me simply return to Lotus live and
select contacts from the people
menu select the contact you want to meet
with and click propose
meeting if they're a tongle me member
you'll see their availability allowing
you to easily propose times if they're
not a tungle me member tungle will begin
a new meeting invitation for you with
the contact already
added you can then propose multiple
times ensuring the meeting is booked
quickly and
easily